foreign
[Music]
The Lion King from 1994 is undeniably
one of the best known and most popular
Disney movies of all time the story
around Simba Mufasa and other characters
still inspires numerous viewers today as
we have known for a while the spin-off
Mufasa The Lion King about Simba's
iconic father will be released next year
in today's original you can find out all
the latest details about the new Disney
film so Hakuna Matata and have fun with
our video
Disney can look back on several
successes in the field of live-action
remakes in recent years one of the most
popular is The Lion King live action
movie from 2019 in which they refrain
from the cult animation style and
instead presented the audience with new
and more modern visuals based on the
information known so far about Mufasa we
can already conclude a few things about
the new film The live-action adaptation
will be a prequel that deals with
Mufasa's earlier life in the
surroundings of The Pride Rock the
relationship between him and his later
enemy brother scar will play a big role
here and we will learn how the two
became Arch Rivals as revealed by a
report from Screen Rant in April 2023
scar will have two sides in the film on
one side he's the sweetest of lions and
on the other we'll get to know his
extremely cunning nature in terms of
story those responsible will probably
more or less follow the original book
which like the original film was also
published in 1994 and bears the title A
Tale of Two Brothers the 61-page book
tells the story of Mufasa and Scar back
when they were still young princes now
the evil brother got his eponymous scar
it involves among other things a fight
with a buffalo on that day taka as
Mufasa's brother was formerly known died
and Scar was born a first impression of
the film could already be gathered at
the d23 Expo last year the footage
showed the young Mufasa on his way to
the pride lands as a child he was left
perilous by a devastating storm surge
and was thus on his own much sooner than
other members of his species his brother
scar who was clearly neglected as a
child will get just as much screen time
as Scar's voice actor Kelvin Harrison Jr
confirmed as we know from past
statements by director Barry Jenkins the
movie has bigger Ambitions than just
being a prequel not only will the
backstory be told for example but many
scenes from the later storyline of the
Lion King will also be taken up
alongside Calvin Harrison Jr ascar
brother actor Aaron Pierre will assume
the role of the Lion King Mufasa taiman
and Pumbaa are also returning serving as
the story's narrators they will be
dubbed as in The Lion King by Seth Rogen
and Bill Eichner likewise joining the
cast is the ancient and wise Shaman
Rafiki who was voiced by South African
actor John Connie it's worth noting that
while new younger actors have been found
for Scar and Mufasa many of the other
characters from the 2019 film have not
been replaced this supports director
Barry Jenkins statements that Mufasa The
Lion King is not a mere prequel
an exact date for the release of the
first trailer is not known yet so far
only the film sequence which is not
available to the public has been shown
at d23 assuming that Mufasa follows a
similar pattern to The Lion King we
shouldn't expect to see any video
material until nine months before the
actual release date currently the
theatrical release of Mufasa The Lion
King is scheduled for July 5th 2024. we
will make sure to keep you up to date on
further news
uh
[Music]